嘿，你最近有沒有注意到一種新的創業模式？它讓我想到，我們平時做生意，是不是太把資源限制當一回事了。
怎麼說？現在創業哪有不被資源限制的？資金、人力、技術，哪一樣不是門檻？尤其是在台灣，中小企業更是感同身受吧。
我今天看到一個案例，它說 AI 正在悄悄地製造百萬富翁，而且重點是，他們創業「沒有員工、沒有程式碼」。
等等，沒有員工，沒有程式碼？這怎麼可能？難道他們都是超級天才，還是有什麼我不知道的黑科技？這聽起來有點像詐騙集團的口號。
其實原文的意思是，他們不是完全沒有員工，而是將 AI 工具發揮到極致，讓 AI 成為他們的「虛擬員工」。這就出乎意料了，一般公司不是都會想盡辦法請人來做事情嗎？
嗯，這確實有點與一般想法不同。但就算 AI 幫忙，一個公司能完全不請人嗎？這模式撐得久嗎？成本真的划算嗎？
原文提到一個例子，有一個非開發者，他只是用「白話文」描述了一個應用程式的功能，結果就透過一個「無程式碼」的工具把它做出來了。
所以重點是「無程式碼」工具，而不是 AI 本身嗎？
兩者都有。AI 在這裡扮演了將白話文轉化為可執行指令的角色。真正的創新點是，這個創業者找到了一個擋住 99% 人進入這個產業的門檻——就是「我不會寫程式」——然後把這個門檻直接移除了。移除門檻本身，就成了產品。
哇，這樣一說就合理多了。意思是他們不是靠 AI 做更多事情，而是用 AI 解決那個最痛、最核心的痛點，也就是技術門檻。
對，就是這個意思。原文還強調，很多成功者其實不是「用更多 AI」，而是把 AI 用在「創造最大財務槓桿的一兩個地方」，其他地方就跳過。這點我覺得很關鍵。
那這樣看來，如果我是個創業者或主管，我可以從這裡學到什麼？是不是應該先去盤點一下，我們公司現在最被哪些「門檻」卡住，然後看看有沒有 AI 工具能把它拆掉？
我猜啦，就是這個。像以前想做個網站或 App，可能要找工程師、花大錢。現在如果用 AI 幫你搞定「程式碼」，那是不是很多想法就能更快實現？而且，原文也提到，有公司部署 AI 聊天機器人取代 700 名客服人員，創造了 4,000 萬美元的利潤。
4,000 萬美元！這數字是真的嗎？這麼大的獲利，那為什麼不繼續用？
這裡就有個很重要的轉折點了。雖然一開始效果驚人，但他們後來又重新僱用了真人客服。原文有說，幾乎沒人問「哪些對話是 AI 絕對不該碰的」。這就點出了 AI 的界線。
這是個好問題。所以 AI 還是有它不能取代的部分，尤其是涉及人際互動、情感判斷的服務？
我覺得是的。這也提醒了我們，AI 雖然強大，但不能盲目追求全面自動化。有些高價值、需要人性化的服務，還是得靠人。
那對於一般上班族來說，這個概念能怎麼帶入自己的工作或生活？難道我也要去學寫 Prompt 成為百萬富翁嗎？
不用這麼極端啦。你可以想想看，你現在工作裡，有沒有什麼重複性高、規則性強，但是又很花時間的「門檻」？比如報表整理、資料篩選。這些東西，現在有沒有 AI 工具能幫你「移除」掉？
就像以前 Excel 公式可以幫我省很多時間一樣，現在 AI 可能也能幫我處理更複雜的任務？
嗯，其實就是這個道理。把那些讓你覺得「我不會、我不能」的事情，看看有沒有 AI 能幫你「可以」。這樣，你就能把精力放在那些真正需要你思考、判斷、創造價值的任務上。
聽你這麼說，好像也提醒了我們，那些阻礙我們前進的「門檻」，或許也正是我們找到新機會的起點。